the dream of the pneumatic tube will
never die
there are a few quirks from mainstream
an oddity at Bank Drive thrus a retro
vision of a smokeless and frictionless
future but the hope lives with
inventions like the Hyperloop that try
to combine pneumatic tubes and maglev
for high-speed transport the thing most
people don't know is how long that dream
has been alive and that they've been
trying to move people for more than 150
years pneumatic tubes are pretty simple
at their most basic sealed tube allows a
fan to make a vacuum when a canister
pops into place a fan whirs to life and
creates a difference in air pressure
that sucks the tube to its destination
as early as the 1850s people adapted
artificial vacuums for powering the mail
system and they sent lots of packages
including cats the New York City
underground pneumatic mail system
launched in 1897 it carried the mail
from one post office to another the
first canister had a Bible a flag and a
copy of the Constitution as an inside
joke the second carried an imitation
peach the third had a black cat it
survived operators called themselves
rocketeers and at its peak the system
could send 200,000 letters an hour it
wasn't close to the first pneumatic mail
systems were surprisingly common they'd
been running in London since the 1850s
and were in Paris Prague Philadelphia
and tons of other places but as cities
spread out and automobiles developed
tubes became too difficult to install
maintain its staff they saw more
widespread adoption in department stores
offices and yes
banks NASA used tubes for memos as inner
office mail tubes were more practical
until smaller offices and email made
them an extravagance there too but the
dream was always bigger than that they
wanted to put people in the canisters
before the mail was the pneumatic
railway including New York's first
subway system 30 years before
construction of today's familiar
underground subway began opened in 1870
Alfred Eli Beach's experimental subway
debuted under Broadway modeled on
experiments in
England it sold more than 400,000 short
rides as just an experiment for New
Yorkers of the era it wasn't a subway it
was an advanced in civilization
like London's Crystal Palace atmospheric
in the 1860s it promised easy clean
transport but Beach's proof-of-concept
closed before more stations could be
built investors got scared
there was no pneumatic disaster just
reality the same thing that eventually
took down the mail took down the
pneumatic subway
it wasn't easy you're cheap enough to be
sustainable the airless tube had too
much friction pneumatic tubes are still
around until 2011 they were used in at
least one McDonald's drive-thru and
they're still used in hospitals to
transport lab samples quickly and safely
from one floor to another but it's the
Hyperloop that has the original spirit
the conviction that the pneumatic tube
isn't a pipe dream it's the idea part
Victorian part Jetsons the tubes won't
just push people from one place to
another but maybe into the future
- any history of pneumatic tubes is
going to involve a lot of omissions I
had to leave out the trash disposal on
Roosevelt Island pneumatic dating and
also the pioneering pneumatic mail in
Philadelphia
where they sent a rooster guinea pigs
and a goldfish in a goldfish bowl
through the pneumatic and none of them
were injured